it's terrible when here we are in 2008
the war in Iraq is still going on is
that's like the big story of the last
five years the big bad story what a
journalist do nothing they became
embedded that's a further explanation
and what I talked about being linear and
being goal-oriented and being sucked in
or an aerospace a personnel carrier or a
tank when Rumsfeld Secretary Defense
Rumsfeld invited the press in and the
great Washington press corps the great
newspapers of our country let reporters
travel with troops and what did that do
that made the press like a mascot to the
military they were traveling with the
American military what do you think they
were getting and get anything they got
maybe propaganda purposes for Rumsfeld
and other the Condoleezza Rice and
Wolfowitz and almost people that
promoting the war the journalists became
sucked into that war there was no great
David Halberstam are the others who in
Vietnam were confronting the government
challenging the president nobody
challenged President Bush nobody
challenged any of these people in charge
since since the war began and the
invasion began 2003 it was really awful
so you say what did they get well they
certainly didn't do any great work they
should have alerted the American public
they should have been critical of the
government they should have been
extremely skeptical at least oh we have
to worry about being patriotic
journalists shouldn't be patriotic they
go to jail it's fine i'm gonna go to
jail but tell the truth and don't report
what's not the truth and don't listen to
the flax in Washington you know as they
speak to you now I probably be old
before we get to the audience but
there's a guy that used to be President
Bush's PR man is spokesperson press
attaché and now he's disavowing his
connection but he was another
merchandiser of Mythology out of the
White House now he's a lot of people
jumping ship now of course but and
selling books as well but the
journalists were were very very lacking
in great courage because they got sucked
into that war and well enough of that
what else well I can't think of I think
the newspapers are well written because
the journalist today are very well
educated but that doesn't mean they have
a particular point of view or vantage
point or way of seeing the world or way
of writing the writing because they're
educated is filled with language that is
the language of the campus of the
well-educated too many I think we become
as a society very class centered because
those who are educated and use the
laptop art are very much in in a kind of
a world of more privileged people but
the journalists when I was a young man
in the 1950s and 60s we were more of the
underclass there were people like me
from the Italians and there are people
there were Jewish a lot of Jewish people
and some Irish and we were the
grandchildren or the children of
newcomers and we had a sense we as
journalists of being on the outside
looking in looking in at power or
looking at at privilege or looking at it
something that was different from what
we thought we were and what we probably
really were because we were probably the
first in our family to get a college
education and not many of us went to
elite schools either this is the 50s and
60s I'm talking about and so we did have
a sense of being of being newcomers to
America and being very with a sense of
wonderment and curiosity and a sense of
not being a member you see the
journalists of today who are 25 35 years
old or a little older probably went to
Harvard Yale you know or the better
Princeton and like schools Stanford with
and and in New York or in Washington
probably belong to the same clubs the
people they're writing about and my day
we journalists weren't we weren't that's
socially acceptable I'm not saying that
well that we were unacceptable I mean we
were we were just outsiders and reveled
in it to a degree we redid revel in it
and we never had a we had a sense of
skepticism which I'm I'm repeating
myself but what an absence of skepticism
of these journalists in the two thousand
of the 21st century and because they all
they go to Washington there must be six
seven thousand journalists in Washington
they all know everyone else they go the
wash and press club and they hang around
with members of government and they all
want to be on Air Force One and they
want access who wants access to these
lies I mean they're did sources I mean
that they cover up all the sources i
mean i am not at all unaware of the
First Amendment I'm an absolutist on the
First Amendment but I also to believe
that the American public deserves to
have those who are being quoted
identified and I don't believe in most
cases those people who are allowed to be
anonymous should be allowed to be
anonymous in print or on television but
that's the rantings of a senior citizen
I'm afraid but that's the way I feel
they're not lazy they got conditioned
into it they became embedded you
understand not lazy i mean i don't think
they know any better it's not that they
willfully are not making that extra step
but they grew up with the technology
beginning with the tape recorder this
goes back 40 years and now with this
whole technology where it's easy it
shouldn't be easy it's easy to Google
you can write stories and you get it and
people the bloggers they're all making
it up and there's no fundamental first
source that is so authoritative that it
holds up there's not this great sense of
inquiry or demand to know or or I want
to see it before I believe it that idea
of looking the faces of the people not
getting it third fourth hand or getting
it from the internet I mean it is that
is a kind of a recycling of triviality
and meaninglessness and and too often
misinformation
you